pastor reinhard zuba wurde gestern tot
in seiner wohnung in berlin moabit
aufgefunden jetzt ist klar der
77-jährige wurde umgebracht die
mordkommission ermittelt
mir ist jetzt die bild-reporter biermann
live zugeschaltet zählt die polizei
bittet um mithilfe wie können wir denn
alle mithelfen die tat aufzuklären
ja wer kannte reinholz aber wer weiß mit
wem er sich womöglich getroffen hat die
nachbarn mit denen ich hier sprechen
konnte berichten dass er ein sehr
freundlicher mann war er war ja 77 jahre
alt aber ein junger mann der ihn kannte
sagte der hat eher den eindruck gemacht
hat sei anfang 60 gewesen er soll
womöglich bei der ece für aktiv gewesen
sein und
die leute hier sind schockiert die
kriminaltechnik war gerade da hat
zahlreiche beweis gegenstände aus der
wohnung heraus getragen hat jetzt die
wohnung versiegelt und es kann sich hier
keiner so wirklich erklären was da
passiert ist
am klingelschild sind zwar zwei namen zu
sehen aber er war wohl meistens alleine
unterwegs und wie gesagt so als der
freundliche herr aus dieser gegend er
ist ja schon etwas über die todesursache
bekannt ja es war schnell klar
dass er durch gewalteinwirkung zu tode
gekommen ist nachbarn hatten mehrere
tage nicht gesehen er muss so schätzt
man mittwoch donnerstag zum tode
gekommen seien und als dann die
feuerwehr die tür aufbrach sahen sie
sofort dass dort wurde eine stumpfe
gewalt gegen den oberkörper
stattgefunden hat so nennt man das in
diesem polizeideutsch und deswegen waren
jetzt auch sofort die kriminalermittler
gestern mit vielen wagen heute noch mal
mit nem mit einem wagen der
kriminaltechnik der kriminaltechnik und
wie gesagt die haben jetzt viele
beweismittel herausgetragen aus der
wohnung und hoffen jetzt dass es einen
hinweis gibt was diesen mann zugestoßen
sein könnte
danke schön herr wie man für deine
aktuellen information